rioters storm the capitol building to
try to stop the electoral college vote
count for joe biden the left blames all
republicans for the insurrection
and twitter suspends trump i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
the show shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com we'll get to
everything
news related in just one moment first
let me remind you you're spending
too much on your cell phone bill did you
know that your family can save over 800
dollars a year
just by switching to puretalk from
verizon att
or t-mobile you can think about it what
would your family do with that extra
money probably not spend it on cell
phone service you don't need instead
check out puretalk they've got the same
coverage same bars as one of the big
carriers but they charge you
half the price why well because the
other carriers they're not going to tell
you this but they are charging you for
unlimited talk text
and unlimited data you don't need
unlimited data nobody has ever used
unlimited data you need two gigs of data
for just 20 bucks a month if you go over
on data usage with pure talk usa
they don't charge you for it and you're
not gonna have to sacrifice customer
service their team is based right here
in the united states they're some of the
nicest people
you will ever talk to grab your mobile
phone dial pound 250 say ben shapiro to
get started save yourself a bundle
when you do you'll save 50 off your
first month as well aside from the other
overall savings style pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
pure talk is simply smarter wireless
again
why would you be spending twice as much
money for the same exact coverage there
is no reason to do this save yourself
some money grab your mobile phone and
dial pound 250 say my name ben shapiro
and say 50
off your first month when you do okay so
yesterday was one of them
was no bar none not one of the the most
horrifying thing that i have seen in
american politics in my lifetime
it was absolutely horrific on every
possible level and we're gonna go
through today
the entire the entire string of events
we're gonna go through the reaction to
the events
which also has been quite terrible so i
guess the the synopsis of today's show
is that everything is terrible that's
that that's the synopsis but what we saw
yesterday is inexcusable
unjustifiable awful on every level
disgusting on every level
just terrible terrible when you have
rioters
taking over the u.s capitol building the
seat of american democracy
and when you have those writers saying
that they are doing so in the name of
the president
of the united states and when you have
them doing that to the legislative
branch
of the government when you have those
people they they are rioters they are
not protesters okay as soon as you
commit an act of vandalism or violence
you are no longer in the category of
protester you are now a rioter
and unlike some folks who have justified
riots
based on the perspective of the rioters
if you're a criminal you're a criminal
and you should go to jail you should go
to jail and this
was an attempted act of insurrection i
mean technically speaking that's what it
was
considering that the reason that this
happened is because congress was simply
there doing their constitutional duty
and tabulating
the state-certified electoral count
that's all they were doing
they do not have the power congress does
not have the power as i have been saying
all week long congress does not
and never did have the power to simply
overturn
state electoral college certified
results that is not a legal thing for
them to do vice president pence did not
have that power
congress did not have that power it was
not going to happen anyway even if you
thought they had that power because
democrats control the house of
representatives
so all of that was tomfoolery it was
nonsense
and folks who believed that it wasn't
nonsense and decided that they were
going to commit
an evil act it is an evil act to invade
the seat of government and do violence
to people it turns out
we now have over a dozen police officers
who are injured there are four people
who are dead one person was shot three
people died in medical emergencies
yesterday
that's as bad an event as i've ever seen
in american public life
frankly i think that in in many ways
it's the worst thing to happen
to the united states of america since 9
11. it's
it's it was cataclysmically awful
cataclysmically awful obviously a very
different sort of thing considering that
911 was a a foreign terror attack
ending with mass carnage and mass death
but the grave damage done
to the sense of democracy to the to the
propriety of a republic
and to the functional workings of our
government yesterday it was pretty awful
it was pretty awful now the american
system is robust and bounced back within
hours
thank god but that does not diminish the
importance of what happened yesterday
which again
was was bad on every single level so
let's start from the very beginning
because that's a very good place to
start as julie andrews might say so
yesterday
there was a lot of lead up there's a lot
of lead up to yesterday i remember the
big news story
in the morning was that the republicans
had lost the senate and the democrats
now had unified control of the
government
and they've been lead up for weeks to
the january 6th vote by congress
to simply count the votes again there is
no
legal basis there is not there is not a
legal basis for the vice presidents of
the united states
to overturn electoral vote counts there
is not a legal basis for congress to
simply throw out electoral vote counts
it doesn't like in the absence
of overwhelming evidence of voter fraud
or voter irregularity especially because
all of these states had already
certified their vote counts within the
statutorily provided safe harbor
provisions
if you were going to make the arguments
you had to make them in court the trump
team did not make those arguments in
court in fact the trump team repeatedly
refused to make fraud arguments in for
example pennsylvania which was most
highly fraught of the states
and as it turns out pretty much nobody
in congress yesterday was even willing
to challenge
the vote count in georgia right after
all of the hubbub and after all the to
do
but in the lead-up president trump was
suggesting
publicly openly and repeatedly that the
january 6th vote was going to overturn
the results of the
electoral college and the results of the
election itself and that he was going to
be reinstalled as president if only if
only the republicans in congress could
find the guts to do so it was not going
to happen
it was a myth it was not true okay so
president trump led a rally yesterday in
which he told people that the election
was stolen from now
he is an american he has the right to
say his peace he has the right to
believe
whatever he wants to believe about
whether the election was stolen or
whether the election
was not stolen however the president of
the united states
should not be doing this obviously
especially when he has not provided the
evidence to back his move he has not
provided the overwhelming evidence the
election was stolen
the reality is the certified vote counts
from a wide variety of states including
two
that were traditionally red states
arizona and georgia went for joe biden
okay the electoral vote count here was
the same as the electoral vote count
trump against hillary clinton which he
himself called the landslide in that
case hillary clinton won the popular
vote here trump lost the popular vote by
seven seven million votes
i i know that there are a lot of
questions about voter irregularity i
know they're are
real serious questions about voter
procedures right voter id and universal
mail and balloting
i fully agree with the latter a lot of
the voting procedures are really bad and
need to be redone
i am not comfortable with people voting
months in advance in universal mail and
balloting
without serious examination of the
of the voter rolls to purge people who
have moved out of state et cetera
but that is not what trump was talking
about right trump kept saying over and
over and over the president
he kept saying over and over and over
that the election had been stolen from
him
and also he had refused repeatedly to
commit to a peaceful transition of power
right this goes all the way back to 2016
when he had refused to say that he would
concede if he lost
now as we'll see yesterday he actually
did say that there would be a peaceful
transition
of power but that should have been
obviously the first word out of his
mouth after the election it should have
been i'm gonna go through all the legal
challenges i believe i won but of course
if the electoral college votes we have a
process in this country there will be a
peaceful transition of power in any case
president trump gave a speech to a very
very large march
tens of thousands of people gathering in
washington dc to what they call stop the
steel
here was president trump yesterday
saying he would never concede under any
circumstances
all of us here today do not want to see
our election victory stolen
by emboldened radical left democrats
which is what they're doing
and stolen by the fake news media that's
what they've done
and what they're doing we will never
give up we will never concede it doesn't
happen you don't concede when there's
theft involved
our country has had enough we will not
take it anymore and that's what this is
all about
okay now obviously those sorts of vague
inflammatory statements uh they're not
good for the republic so let me just say
this
right from the outset there are a lot of
people today saying that trump is
responsible for the actual riot that
happened
at the capitol building so i have a very
strict standard you can go back in time
you can look at how
i've applied the standard okay it's a
very very strict standard when it comes
to saying that someone is directly
responsible for violence done
by another adult human being and that is
if you didn't tell somebody to do the
violence you're not
technically responsible for the violence
right i said this about barack obama
when when a black lives matter supporter
shot six police officers
in dallas after months of obama
suggesting that the police were
systemically racist
i said that is not on barack obama
barack obama is responsible for raising
the temperature to the point
where people do bad things that he is
responsible for he is not responsible
for the actual shooting i said the same
thing about bernie sanders bernie
sanders claimed for
months for years on end that republicans
were killing old people
and that republicans were attempting to
have people die for lack of health care
and then
a bernie sanders supporter went and shot
a bunch of congress people including
steve scalise who almost died
i did not say that bernie sanders was
responsible for that because bernie
sanders was not responsible for that
bernie sanders did not tell the guy to
go shoot
members of congress i have a very strict
standard and i have applied it
on every single side of this particular
issue with that said when you raise the
temperature
when you keep raising the temperature
when you keep boiling the pot
then eventually it's going to bubble
over and when you keep saying over and
over that the election is stolen
and that we and makes big statements we
are not going to stand for it we're not
going to let this happen in our country
right when you suggest that members of
congress are acting treasonously i mean
it is it is an accusation essentially
of acting seditiously if you know that
the election was stolen and you vote for
it anyway
then it is not entirely unpredictable
that people are going to act out in this
way
so two things can be true at once as
always one you are not guilty of
somebody else's direct violent conduct
unless you directed them to do that
direct violent conduct but you are
guilty for the language that you speak
right you are responsible for the
promulgation of untruths
you are responsible for the for the
raising of the temperature
you're responsible for misleading people
about the proper response
to something like this we do have legal
processes and the president eventually
came around
to the legal processes last night at
least publicly
but we'll get some more of this in just
one second because obviously
that was just the beginning of the day
yesterday and much more happened from
there
first something lighter something
lighter something wonderful okay
i know we're all going to take a breath
okay waffles
waffles they're great and what can i say
stuffler waffles okay the presto stuffer
stuffed waffle maker it is
it's like the best device my kids love
this thing so every sunday morning this
has now become a shapiro family
tradition we get out that presto stuff
our stuffed waffle maker we grab our
waffle mix
and we put it in the in the waffle maker
we put a layer of waffle you put
whatever filling you want
peanut butter cups strawberries
blueberries nuts cheese like whatever
you want in there
and then you pour a little bit more
batter on the top you flip it over you
let it cook for like 10 minutes
and you get the best waffle you've ever
had i mean these stuffed waffles are
just
unbelievable it's so easy to use it's
really cleverly designed
the presto stuffer works with most any
batter instant box from scratch not just
waffle mixes cake muffin brownie
cornbread
presto provides dozens of recipes and
ideas for intriguing batters and
delicious fillings you can even dye it
with a stuffed waffle
you can use one of the no or low-carb
gluten-free keto batters you can fill it
with protein you can fill it with
veggies you can even make nutrition
delicious with the presto stuffler
stuffed waffle maker it's an amazing
awesome product my family loves it my
kids love it
in fact when we had relatives who are in
the general area they came over and they
were desperate to use it because they'd
heard me talk about it
they were indeed impressed head on over
to www.stuffler that's
s-t-u-f-f-l-e-r.com
click buy now add to cart and enter
promo code ben to get 10
off and free shipping remember that's
stuffler.com promo code ben at checkout
for that amazing
waffle maker okay well now that we've
gotten beyond happy thoughts we'll get
back to uh
less happy events happening in the
united states okay so president trump
continued his speech yesterday again
this is in front of tens of thousands of
people
uh fairly early yesterday morning here
was president trump slamming his own
supreme court appointees
who he said he was disappointed in for
not overruling the state electoral
accounts in the in these various in
these various areas
and again there's no indicator that the
supreme court saw
any evidence sufficient to overturn
election results
they turned down the pennsylvania case
on the basis
that there was a serious problem with
the federal court adjudicating what was
in fact a state legislative matter
okay but but even there i believe it was
a 7-2 ruling
even there the the two who voted in
favor of taking the case
suggested pretty openly that does not
mean that they would have voted in favor
of overturning the electoral results
from pennsylvania in any case president
trump slammed his own supreme court
appointees in front of this very large
crowd yesterday
i'm not happy with the supreme court
they love to rule against me i picked
three
people i fought like hell for him one in
particular i thought
they all said sir cut him loose he's
killing the senators you know very loyal
senators they're very loyal people
sir cut him loose he's killing us sir
cut him loose sir i'll never i must have
gotten
half of the senators i said no i can't
do that it's unfair to him and it's
unfair to the family
he didn't do anything wrong they made up
stories they were all made up stories he
didn't do anything wrong
caught a blue sir i said no i won't do
that we got them through
and you know what they couldn't give a
damn they couldn't give a damn
let them rule the right way but it
almost seems that they're all going
out of their way to hurt all of us and
to hurt our country okay i mean this is
honestly it's really bad stuff it's it's
it's gross it is gross i mean when the
president suggests that the supreme
court is going out of the way to rule
against him
even though i got them through and they
owe me an oath of personal loyalty
that's not how the government works
that is not how the government was ever
designed to work as a government of laws
not of men it is not a personal loyalty
test to any one person it never should
be a personal loyalty test to any one
person democratic republican black white
or green
okay so then president trump finishes
this rally
by by saying that he's going to lead all
these people on a march down to the
capitol building
okay so this as this is happening by the
way congress is meeting
to discuss the the state electoral
results
and again the way that process works is
we'll discuss is the vice president
opens the votes he counts the votes he
does not have the power to throw out the
votes
the congress of the united states if you
get one congress person and one senator
they can then challenge any state
electoral result
on the basis of either illegal
certification
or they can say there was bribery that
happened something like that okay
then there is a separate debate for each
house of congress they come back
together they vote on it
it was a foregone conclusion that that
tactic was going to be a failure
uh the congress is just not given this
sort of responsibility the federal
government does not have the ability to
simply overrule state electoral college
results for the one thousandth time
and it's just not a legal reality in any
case president trump says i'm going to
lead you on a march here's here's the
conclusion of the speech
and after this we're going to walk down
and i'll be there with you
we're going to walk down we're going to
walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going to walk down
to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them okay so he says going to
lead a march on the capital he in fact
did not lead a march on the capital he
went back to the white house
the march on the capitol then proceeded
okay so while all of this is happening
it's like something out of a horrible
bee film while all of this is happening
the vice president of the united states
mike pence
releases a statement saying no i'm not
going to simply overthrow
an election and simply hand the election
to my boss like that's not a thing that
i'm going to do
he put out a letter earlier yesterday in
which he said our founders created the
electoral college in 1787
at first convened in 1789 with the
advent of political parties the
electoral college was amended in 1804 to
provide that electors vote separately
for president and vice president
congress spent a decade after 1876
establishing rules and procedures to
govern the counting of electoral votes
and the resolution of any objections
during the 130 years since the electoral
account act was passed
congress has without exception used
these formal procedures to count the
electoral votes
every four years given the controversy
surrounding this year's election
some approach this year's quadrennial
tradition with great expectations others
with dismissive disdain some believe
that his vice president i should be able
to accept or reject electoral votes
unilaterally
others believe electoral votes should
never be challenged in a joint session
of congress
after a careful study of our
constitution our laws our history i
believe
neither of you is correct the presidency
belongs to the american people and to
them alone when disputes concerning a
presidential
a presidential election arise under
federal law rights vice president pence
it is the people's representatives who
review the evidence and resolve the
disputes through a democratic process
and then he continues
investing the vice president with
unilateral authority to decide
presidential contests would be entirely
antithetical
to that design which of course is
exactly right
he said that he would gather he would do
his duty and then he would
he would do it in a manner consistent
with our constitutional laws and history
so help me god right so pence announces
that i am not going to be overturning
the results of the election
and the debate begins in the senate
senator ted cruz
is one of the leaders of the effort to
challenge electoral results
and senator cruz gets up and he and he
explains why he is doing this
we have seen and no doubt will continue
to see
a great deal of moralizing from both
sides of the aisle
but i would urge to both sides perhaps
a bit less certitude
and a bit more recognition that we are
gathered at a time when democracy
is in crisis recent polling shows that
39 percent of americans
believe the election that just occurred
quote
was rigged you may not agree with that
assessment
but it is nonetheless a reality for
nearly half the country
i would note it is not just republicans
who believe that
31 of independents
agree with that statement 17
of democrats believe the election was
rigged
okay this is a very very very poor
argument it is a bad argument that
because a lot of people believe a thing
therefore we are going to
misuse the legal process in order to in
order to what
make excuses for the thing that's not
going to end with anything changing
okay the the reality is as i have said
again i have very consistent standards
when it comes to this sort of stuff
allegations must be substantiated by
evidence we have over 50 court cases in
which these allegations were not
properly substantiated by evidence we
have had open
senate we have had open legislative
hearings in a variety of
purple states in in in states that went
from trump to biden
right we have we've had a series of
hearings in which the evidence presented
has been has been put forth it has not
been particularly convincing
okay just because a lot of people
believe a thing does not mean that you
should grant legitimacy
to the thing they believe when the
evidence is simply not there so mitch
mcconnell the senate majority leader
he gets up and he says exactly this and
frankly good for mcconnell good for
mcconnell
so here is here's mitch i've had many
problems with mitch mcconnell over the
years
uh this is not one of them here's mitch
mcconnell yesterday saying that listen
regardless of what you believe the
evidence of fraud is not honest it has
not been substantiated to the scale
where it would overturn the presidential
election this is obviously true
based on the evidence that has been
examined at this time
all rumors to the contrary and they did
several re-votes
in recounts of the vote in georgia they
investigated all the allegations in
georgia up to including the allegations
the dead people were voting
up to it including the allegations at
the state farm arena
here's mitch mcconnell saying the
evidence is not there
nothing before us proves illegality
anywhere near the massive scale
the massive scale it would have
tipped the entire election
okay and mcconnell then continued he
said you know one of the things that's
happening in this country and it's
pretty egregious is we cannot have
separate sets of facts that are being
put forth
we cannot keep drifting apart
into two separate tribes with a separate
set of facts
and separate realities
with nothing in common except our
hostility towards each other and
mistrust for the few national
institutions
that we all still share okay and then
finally mcconnell concludes and he says
if the election were actually overturned
if some of these folks got what they
wanted
we would basically be in a civil war
which is of course correct
let's say that congress decided they
were just going to throw out all of the
state votes
they were going to disenfranchise tens
of millions of people in these various
states
and simply enshrine donald trump for a
second turn
you really think there wouldn't be mass
no not what we saw yesterday mass
violence in the streets like open chaos
and civil war
there would be it would also be morally
wrong you don't get to overthrow
state-certified electoral college
results on the congressional level
because you don't like the result here's
mcconnell yesterday
this election were overturned by mere
allegations from the losing side
our democracy would enter a death spiral
we'd never see the whole nation except
an election again
every four years would be a scramble for
power
at any cost jesus mcconnell was right
about all
of that okay so as this is happening
president trump tweets out
against mike pence and we now know by
the way that
the the president apparently has banned
mark short the vice president's chief of
staff from even entering the white house
at this point so this is uh the fit of
peak has not yet ended so trump
tweeted out mike pence didn't have the
courage to do what should have been done
to protect our country and our
constitution giving states a chance to
certify a corrected set of facts
not the fraudulent or inaccurate ones
which they were asked to previously
certify
usa demands the truth okay well this is
where again
are you responsible for raising the
temperature you damn sure well are when
you do that sort of stuff
i mean what exactly does he think the
remedy is at this point he's taken it to
every court in the land
all the courts have said he didn't
provide the evidence he took it to state
legislatures
they said you're not providing enough
evidence for us to overturn the will of
the people
okay like what the vice president isn't
going to break the law congress isn't
going to break the law
and then when he says the usa demands
the truth like
in in what way in what way what is the
practical way in which this is true
right how is that going to happen what
is that supposed to mean
now again that doesn't mean he is
calling for violence it does mean
that he is responsible for radically
raising the temperature as he has been
for the last couple of months
based on allegations that have been
unverified and unproven and in many
cases overtly debunked
and none of this is to say voter fraud
and voter regularity didn't take place
or that we shouldn't have investigations
into criminally
serious criminal allegations i said that
every single day
since the election none of this means
that we shouldn't take a look
at the voter laws that govern in a lot
of these states which in fact are not
good
but the president has been making
unverified unverifiable and in some
cases
overtly falsified allegations about the
nature of this election
and he has whipped people up into such a
in such a fervor
by by suggesting over and over and over
again that there are remedies available
to them that are simply not available to
them and then what happens when they run
out of remedies
what happens when there are no more
remedies available
okay so in a second we'll get to what
what then happened what happened next
which of course is the dramatic event of
it yesterday and one of the worst things
that i have seen
in my political life and down playing it
is not worthy of conservatives
downplaying it is not worthy of people
who call themselves protectors of the
constitution
protectors of civil liberties and civil
rights it is not worthy of that
and by the way you know the sort of what
about ism that is now applying
the reason that it is bad when the left
greenlit antifa and blm riots
during the summer is because that is bad
okay and it's just as bad
if you are green lighting stuff like
that from people that you have sympathy
for
okay double standards apply both ways
and we'll get to all of that
all of that and more in just one second
first let's talk
about life insurance so it's pretty
obvious at this point everybody needs
life insurance what a year this has been
it is a year that reminds you that it
would be good to protect your family in
case god forbid something should happen
to you and this is why you need life
insurance policy genius
makes it easy for you to compare more
than 30 top insurers at once and save
over 50
in the process there's no hassle they're
licensed experts work for you not the
insurance companies here's how it works
first head on over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape if you
hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything for you that kind of service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across over 1 600 reviews
on trustpilot and google make this the
year you finally cross life insurance
off your list
get protection for your loved ones go to
policygenius.com and get started you
could say 50
or more by comparing quotes start the
new year with one less thing to worry
about policy genius when it comes to
insurance it is nice
and quite quite important to get it
right okay so
all of this culminates in a riot at the
capitol building
and congress itself being put under
siege congress has to go into recess
uh the i spoke to several congress
people yesterday who were rushed into
safe spots in the capital building
senators were all being housed together
various congress people were being
sheltered in their offices protected by
capitol police and in some cases secret
service
lawmakers staff members according to the
ap were hiding under tables hunkered in
lockdown saying prayers
seeing the fruits of the country's
divisions up close and violent guns were
drawn the images are absolutely stunning
the guns were drawn in the capital
chamber they're barbaric literally
people dressed as barbarians
taking over the capital chamber sitting
in the vice president's seat you can see
this image secret service agents
pointing guns
at one of the at one of the doors as
people try to break into the doors
of the capitol building one woman was
shot dead
uh the footage of that is too gruesome
for me to show you
she was unarmed she she was attempting
to climb up into the chamber in criminal
fashion and she was shot by a capital
police officer
and she uh she died uh the three other
people apparently died in various
medical emergencies
around the around the periphery of the
of the riot according to the ap the
pro-trump mob took over the presiding
officer's chair in the senate the
officers of the house speaker and the
senate diaz where one yelled trump won
the election
they mocked its leaders they posed for
photos in the office of house speaker
pelosi
one with his feet propped on a desk in
her office another sitting in the same
seat
vice president pence had occupied only
moments before during the proceedings to
certify
the electoral college vote the rioters
began by mobbing the media
right so they actually just started
tearing away cameras
this is criminal activity all these
people should spend time in jail
you can you can see the video they
literally just went up to members of the
media and they started mobbing them
and and destroying their their cameras
okay this is criminal activity is called
criminal activity this is criminal
activity
you can hear the chaos you can see them
stealing and or wrecking the equipment
these folks are delight then the mob
took over the capitol you can actually
see the footage of the moment that the
mob took over the capitol building
injuring police officers
in the process they uh they simply push
right through the gates
so the police officers are are standing
there they were lined up on the steps
here you can see uh this man dressed as
a barbarian the writers of this season
are really too on the nose i think when
you have like actual people dressed as
actual barbarians
trying to break into the us capitol
building the seat of the most
the most long-lasting and powerful
democracy in the history of the world
having the guy dressed as a barbarian is
a little bit on the nose so people
simply just bust through the gates
and move their way into the capitol
people waving trump flags people
shouting carrying american flags
a couple carrying confederate flags
which is always a great look
so folks folks you know breaking in
the footage is pretty stunning there
there are people who are chasing down
police officers
there are pictures of blood on the floor
they're rioters who are attempting to to
yeah you can see the footage there blood
on the floor
you can see rioters attempting to bust
through
the doors using uh using some of the
gates as battering rams
naturally they uh these idiots uh
festooned the the battering rams which
they were trying to break into the halls
of democracy with a with the trump flag
[Applause]
it's uh it was egregious it was
egregious and this lasted for hours
okay and this did this did raise serious
questions which we'll get to in a moment
about the nature of the capital police
response and where the hell were they
and where was the national guard and how
was this like if terrorists had known it
would be this easy to take over the us
capitol building
isis had to be sitting there going man
what morons are we why had we not tried
this before
okay so the republicans so the response
across the board
is absolute shock horror and it should
be shocking horror because
i've never seen anything like this have
you ever seen anything like this i
haven't
the only things that i've seen that are
remotely like this like even in any
remote way
there's a situation back in 2011 when
some protesters took over
the uh the capitol building in wisconsin
during a union fight
and they're they're kavanaugh protesters
who like banged on the doors of the
supreme court but the full-scale
takeover of the
of the capitol building and the
destruction of property wholesale
and the wounding of police officers too
are in the hospital
the shooting of a of a rioter right
in the halls of congress egregious
agrees your stuff okay so president
so so vice president pence tweets his
response to all of this
vice president pence tweeted out the
violence and destruction taking place at
the us capital must stop and it must
stop now
anyone involved must respect law
enforcement officers and immediately
leave the building okay so strong
condemnation of course
mccarthy kevin mccarthy the house
minority leader republican leader in the
house
he said yesterday this is un-american
which of course it absolutely is
this is so un-american i condemn any of
this violence is happening in the
capitol right now
i could not be fatter or more
disappointed
with the way our country looks at this
very moment people are getting
hurt anyone involved in this you're
hearing me
getting very loud and clear this is not
the american way
this is not protected by the first
amendment this must stop
now okay then uh joe biden gets up they
they activate him
from the basement in wilmington and he
gets up and he gives what i thought
honestly was a was a fairly decent
statement
and the president-elect he gets up and
he says the democracy
is under assault which again it was i
mean these were people overtly
attempting to disrupt democratic
procedures from taking place
in an attempt to in an attempt to
prevent him from being present in some
adult-brained way
this was never going to work it was
idiotic in the extreme it's illegal it's
criminal and it's gross
here is vice president well now
president-elect biden condemning this
at this hour our democracy is under
unprecedented assault
unlike anything we've seen in modern
times
an assault on the citadel of liberty
the capital itself
an assault on the people's
representatives
and the capitol hill police sworn to
protect them
and the public servants who work
at the heart of our republic
an assault on the rule of law
like few times we've ever seen it
okay and then he continued he said that
he called on president trump to go on tv
and call for an end to this because
while this was going on president trump
had not gone on tv as we'll see trump
had tweeted a couple of times we'll get
to trump's response in just one moment
here was the president-elect
the words of a president matter
no matter how good or bad that president
is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
therefore i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath and defend the
constitution
and demand an end to this siege
okay so uh then then you know biden made
a statement about how this wasn't about
him it was really about democracy and
regardless of what you think of his
characterization of trump's remarks the
reality is that
these folks were proclaiming themselves
from followers trump needed to do
something and trump did a couple of
things so what here's what trump did so
trump tweeted out a couple of things
he tweeted out originally uh that
the violence should stop he said i'm
asking for everyone at the us capital to
remain peaceful no violence remember we
are the party of law and order respect
the law
and our great men and women in blue
thank you and then he tweeted out also
please support our capitol police and
law enforcement they are truly on the
side of our country
stay peaceful okay so he did tweet those
two things out
then maybe a couple hours later hour and
a half later
he released a video okay in this video
he
had two messages which don't have to be
in conflict but uh
are somewhat in conflict one is that he
doubts the outcome of the election
and the other is that all these people
should go home and stop being violent
as i say it's a free country you're
allowed to doubt whatever you want when
the president of the united states keeps
raising the temperature by suggesting
that the election was stolen and that
every avenue of legal
recourse has been closed that does
create the impetus for people to do some
pretty nasty things
but here is the president's statement he
did in fact call for people to stand
down and stop this
here is the statement i know your pain
i know you're hurt we had an election
that was stolen from us it was a
landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us
from me from you from our country this
was a fraudulent
election but we can't play into the
hands
of these people we have to have peace
so go home we love you you're very
special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home in peace okay go
home in peace is a good message
the election was stolen from you it was
a landslide election there's no legal
recourse for us to reclaim that
no one has ever been screwed like i've
been screwed no one's being screwed like
you're being screwed you saw how they
treated everybody with kid gloves when
they rioted back during the summer and
now they're treating you and they're
going to use it as an excuse
there are some mixed messages there
there's some mixed messages there those
mixed messages were exacerbated
by one more tweet that president trump
sent which as we'll see resulted
in him being suspended from twitter
entirely which of course is the wrong
response by twitter
trump tweeted out these are the things
and events that happen when a sacred
landslide election victory is so
unceremoniously and viciously stripped
away from great patriots who have been
badly and unfairly treated for so long
go home with love and in peace remember
this day forever
that does not sound like the opposition
to criminals committing acts of
vandalism and violence against federal
buildings
that uh that he had against antifa or
blm back during the summer
right he we passed executive orders he
promised an executive order
looking to prosecute anybody who
destroyed a federal monument for
for 10 years in prison i mean this was a
major issue during the summer
and regardless of whether he whipped
people into a frenzy
i mean the fact is there if he wants to
say that he is not responsible for for
the violence
which i don't think that he is then why
exactly is he is he saying that
well why exactly he should not be
remember this day these are great
patriots who are committing acts of
vandalism and violence and they're doing
so
because they're angry okay it is wrong
when so barack obama
did some of this stuff during the during
the ferguson riots he would say well you
know people don't feel like this out of
nowhere you have to understand their
feelings yeah the rioting is bad but and
i ripped obama at the time
and this that statement is is agree that
is not a good statement it is not a good
statement and people who are trying to
twist that into
well he's just calling for peace there
calling for peace at the same time
that you suggest overtly and and
repeatedly
that the election was stolen a landslide
election was overtly stolen which is a
subversion of the democratic process
that that is not likely to fall on ears
that are likely to hear that as
oh yeah what you're doing is really bad
right now okay so
president trump finally this morning
came out and pledged
an orderly transfer of power which this
should have happened again literally the
day
before the it should have happened years
ago right he said even though i totally
disagree with the outcome of the
election and the facts bear me out
nevertheless there will be an orderly
transition on january 20th
i've always said we would continue our
fight to ensure that only legal votes
were counted
while this represents the end of the
greatest first term in presidential
history
it's only the beginning of our fight to
make america great
again okay so he says there will be an
orderly transition would have been nice
if uh if he had been saying that
repeatedly and overtly and over and over
and over again
for the last two months minimum even as
he pursued his legal recourses
which again i said he had the right to
pursue i said
every day on this program every legal
recourse is open to him
once those are exhausted the process has
played out and it's over
okay we'll get to the narratives are
going to be drawn from this because the
narratives are
going to be what you have to live with
after this right after this horrible
horrible day is over
and it is after the after the tear gas
has dissipated after the senate is put
back in working order and all the papers
are restored and all the desks are
rebuilt
after the morning is done for the woman
who was shot and killed at the capitol
building
after all that is over then we're going
to have to deal with the fallout
and the narratives are the fallout so
we'll get to the narratives in just
one second because the ramifications for
conservatives and for the republic
are pretty dire i don't have a lot of
trust that this is going to be the the
beginning of a reunification of the
country in any serious way
get to that in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that you are
spending way too much money on your auto
parts you are you went down to that auto
parts store didn't you
and then you stood in line for a long
time and then you got to the front and
they didn't have the part they ordered
it online then they up charged you why
wouldn't you just be skipping the
middleman
and going to rockauto.com it's so much
easier than walking into a store and
someone demanding quick answers to
things like is your odyssey an lx or an
ex
and then they usually just have to order
the part online anyway because there are
lots of types of cars it's impossible to
keep them all stocked
well you have access to rockauto.com at
your desk and in your pocket just do it
yourself
and you can save a ton of money let's
say hypothetically you happen to need a
delphi fg1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey
and it costs like 354 bucks at a big
chain store well rock auto that's 217
bucks
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about his box so they know that we sent
you
alrighty so in just one second we'll get
to the narratives that are gonna be
drawn from this
and that's the stuff you're gonna have
to live with it's gonna shape the
country for the next
several years minimum and uh these
narratives are
wrong thoroughly wrong in many cases
they're
extraordinary like factually wrong quite
ugly
and they're going to have real
consequences for the way that we
live politically and live with each
other in the country we'll get to that
in a second
first as you'll see it's going to a lot
of this is going to be tied into
the narratives that the left has about
about conservatives
right the big point that they are going
to make coming out of this is that all
conservatives are responsible for the
actions of an egregious few
who have committed an act that is
roundly condemned by every conservative
of any size scope or following right
they're going to try and label but
that's what the media do
that's what that's what the the left's
grip on the institutional culture
means that they try to cram down visions
of conservatives that turn conservatives
into the barbarians who stormed the
gates well we need to fight back in the
culture
the way to fight back in the culture is
by providing alternatives if people are
shaped by the entertainment they watch
they're shaped by netflix they're shaped
by amazon
they're shaped by the movies and tv that
they view that is why we are getting
into the entertainment business here at
daily wire we're releasing our first
feature film run hide fight
on friday january 15th for daily wire
members you can check out the trailer
over at the dailywire youtube
right now meanwhile one of the reasons
you should subscribe to daily wire more
generally is because we are trying
to fight back against an establishment
media that lies to you on a regular
basis
and it doesn't tell you the truth and
that acts as a partisan wing for the
democratic party and for the woke left
if you want to fight that the best way
to fight that is get involved in the
cultural battles and the best way to do
that
is to help us out here over at
dailywiredailywire.com
subscribe you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty so there are three narratives
and one set of overt actions that are
going to be taken now that are really
truly
horrifying for the republic so there are
three narratives that started to make
the rounds
around twitter and then of course
filtered their way into the media and
now will become part of the broad public
debate one was the attempt to make this
about race which is unbelievable
i mean literally you had a white woman
who was shot to death right when she
died
at the hands of the capitol police in
the united states capitol building
after rioting and entering that building
illegally
and the takeaway from the media is that
if these were black protesters or
rioters then everyone would have been
shot right this is the take of jamel
hill who can reliably make anything
into a racial comment so jamel hill says
let's just be clear about something the
reason the capital police were slow to
respond
is because they gave these white people
the benefit of the doubt and treated it
like a joke
the reaction isn't the same because they
see black people as a threat that needs
to be eliminated
well i'm gonna go through exactly why
capitol police responded the way they
did in just one second dwyane wade said
the same thing
the basketball player black people get
pulled over and don't make it out alive
okay first of all that's just it's on a
statistical level that is not true
millions of people every year are pulled
over in the united states of america
the number of people who are shot
unarmed by the police
is in the low double digits to single
digits black americans
we but says wait we can't sleep in our
own beds without being killed
again a lie we can't jog without being
killed again a lie
we can't walk down the street with our
hoodies up without being killed but they
can do this
and that of course is so this is the
case that's made is that
because the capitol police and national
guard
didn't put this thing down with
prejudice that that is an indicator of
generalized american white supremacy
first of all the capital police should
have put this thing down with prejudice
second of all the national guard should
have been there and they should have
been doing something as we will see
it was local politicians and federal
politicians who decided
federal bureaucrats who decided they
didn't want enough law enforcement there
partially as a response to criticism
that they received back in the summer
that they were too harsh with the
protesters
and you have joy reid a reliable source
of insanity who says the exact same
thing here is joy reid
white americans aren't afraid of the
cops
white americans are never afraid of the
cops even when they're committing
insurrection even when they're engaged
in attempting to
occupy our capital to steal the votes of
people who look like me
because in their minds they own this
country they own that capital
they own the cops the cops work for them
and people like me have no
damn right to try to elect a president
because we don't get to pick the
president they get to pick the president
they own the president they own the
white house
they own this country okay the white
people own the car i mean like
what kind of sick perverse notion is
this you turn how
to turn this into a racial issue is
beyond beyond insane
beyond insane especially because you
know why this happened
according to the federalist washington's
washington dc mayor muriel bowser
right a black woman who let people and
actually mandated
that they turn a an entire plaza into
black lives matter plaza they painted
black lives matter on an entire
city street in washington dc she told
federal law enforcement to stand down
just one day before a mob of trump
supporters breached the us capital on
wednesday smashing windows entering
chambers
forcing lawmakers and congressional
staff inside into lockdown
bowser wrote in a letter to u.s acting
attorney general jeffrey rosen
acting secretary of defense chris miller
and secretary of the army ryan d
mccarthy to be clear
the district of columbia is not
requesting other federal law enforcement
personnel
and discourages any additional
deployment without immediate
notification to
and consultation with mpd if such plans
are underway according to bowser dc's
metropolitan police department in
coordination with park police capital
police and secret service were well
equipped to handle whatever problems
could come up during the trump rallies
planned for wednesday
she said the district of columbia
government has not requested personnel
from any other law enforcement agencies
to avoid confusion we ask that any
additional request for assistance be
coordinated using the same process and
procedures
according to the wall street journal the
capitol police were not prepared for the
rioters
apparently federal authorities had plans
to deal with the protest this week with
a relatively small minimally visible
presence according to law enforcement
officials
hoping to avoid inflaming tensions as a
show of force had done during the unrest
last year in portland oregon and other
cities
so remember the entire left suggested
that the violence in portland was due to
federal authorities being in portland
so now in response the feds were like
we're not going to put people at the
capitol
great idea everyone it worked out
fantastically well but apparently this
is all a race thing
it's because the protesters were white
yesterday
and beyond that can we remember back to
the blm protests
can you remember the fact that there
were 16 22 bipolar data 16 to 25
million protesters across the country
their grand total
of 14 000 arrests during the months-long
blm protests
entire cities were shut for weeks in
terms of curfew
la wa was shut down for a week in terms
of curfew melrose avenue was allowed to
burn
he said don't give me the the that don't
give me
this bull crap that this is about how
america's a white supremacist country so
they allow this
they let this go on in la in dc in new
york in seattle
in port like they let regardless of the
re of antifa white antifa
jackasses or blm rioters they let it go
on
right like making it about races is
crappy narrative number one crappy
narrative number two
is of course the the media spending
months and months and months
to claiming that rioting was fine so
long as they agreed with the writers
antifa didn't exist joe biden said that
antifa was just a philosophy
chris cuomo went on national television
he said who says that who says that
right that protests have to be peaceful
why should they have to be peaceful this
is just a couple of months ago
it was back in june here was chris cuomo
of cnn
too many see the protests as the problem
no the problem is what forced your
fellow citizens
to take to the streets persistent and
poisonous
inequities and injustice and please
show me where it says that protests are
supposed to be polite
and peaceful because i can show you that
outraged citizens
are the ones who have made america what
she is and led to any major milestones
oh weird be honest this is not a
tranquil
time oh how magical the i mean it's
almost as though there's a massive
double standard that the media will
apply to rioting and looting
why it's incredible by the way if you're
on the right and you're now looking at
this and going well it's okay what
happened at the capitol you're doing the
same thing in reverse
okay but the left did this across the
entirety of the media it wasn't rioting
it was mostly peaceful protest
mostly peaceful right for months don't
gaslight us with this garbage or you
suggest that you're always against
political violence you're not
you're just not okay like that's that's
not the case so you don't have a lot of
legs to stand on
when it comes to this so that's
narrative number two right which is
which is the the media suggesting that
riots are okay for the left but very bad
for the right when the answer is riots
are very bad for everyone they're a
violation of law they are criminality
they are evil you don't get to do that
in a democratic republic
i mean aoc tweeted out back during the
the early days of blm
she tweeted out that that protests are
supposed to make you uncomfortable
that's the goal of protest why is
everybody so upset about protests making
people full essays about why rioting and
looting were justified
back during the summer so that's
narrative number two is that
when when pro-trump people riot that
it's
uniquely bad as opposed to blm people
rioting the answer is it's all
really bad you want to live in a
republic together we're going to have to
acknowledge that political violence
is terrible horrible it cuts directly
against the grain
of the democratic republics that's a
narrative number two and by the way that
double standard does fuel
an enormous amount of rage by folks who
are who are
on the right that rate should never end
in violence but you can see why people
are upset about the double standard okay
and then there is narrative number three
and this is the one that is going to be
the the big
takeaway this is the big takeaway that
the the left is pushing the hardest
after everything that happened yesterday
and that is every conservative is
responsible for what happened yesterday
and this is the takeaway doesn't matter
every single
every single major republican politician
every single conservative commentator
looked at what happened yesterday
in absolute horror the the takeaway
from the media and from the left but i
repeat myself
is that every conservative is
responsible for this
that's absurd that is absurd just as not
every democrat
is responsible for blm riots just as not
every democrat is responsible for the
congressional baseball shooting
just as people who voted for joe biden
are not responsible
for people who burn down storefronts
to suggest that every single one of
these 73 million people who voted for
donald trump is responsible
for a bunch of violent jackass thugs
taking over the capitol building
to suggest that is is patently absurd
offensive ridiculous
and deliberately motivated because the
left constantly does this right this is
the constant suggestion the constant
suggestion
is when a bad thing happens it is
attributable to conservatives
speaking their minds freely and this is
where the rubber is going to meet the
road this is going to be the culture for
the next few years
is that everybody on the right is going
to be cuddled into silence
based on them pointing at somebody who
does something clearly violative of
conservative principles like storming
the capitol building
so once again i quote the id of the
democratic party joy reid
she says no no all conservatives are
responsible doesn't matter if you
condemned it
doesn't matter if you think this is
crazy it doesn't matter if you even
stood
if you stood against the the attempts to
overturn the election
if you stood against what some of the
members of congress were doing in their
election challenges
right everybody is complicit right if
you if you voted for trump if you
considered voting for trump
then you are complicit and this is the
goal it's not to to
heal here's the reality 95 of the
country looks at jackasses on the
fringes and things hey look jackass is
on the fringes
but not the members of the democratic
media for them
the jackasses on the fringe those those
are used to paint every republican and
this has been the constant practice of
the media for literally years on end
the constant practice of the media has
been find a republican saying something
bad then ask every single republican in
america what they think about the person
saying something bad
right that is con meanwhile no democrat
has ever had to answer for anything
radical ever said by any democrat
ever but every republican will be made
responsible for something
that it doesn't matter if you overtly
condemned it doesn't matter if you if
you thought it was horrifying what
happened yesterday
none of that matters according to joy
reid you're complicit too
the elected officials who had a job
today that's in the constitution
that they were supposed to do to
officially and ceremonially
install the new president to show that
we believe in this peaceful transfer of
power
we're completely thrown over today josh
hawley should resign in ignominy it is
absolutely ignominious what he did
sparking this ted cruz as well
but honestly mitch mcconnell too they've
all
played a role conservative media has
played a role they've all
played this game because they thought
that there was no downside
okay so there it is everyone's
responsible mitch mcconnell
who who condemned this who who stood
against the electoral
college attempt mitch mcconnell is
responsible right and by the way here
was mitch mcconnell on the floor
yesterday after they reconvened right
remember he is overseeing
the electoral vote count he's he's one
of the people overseeing this because
he's the senate majority leader
and he's counting into the presidency
joe biden
a person he opposed here was mitch
mcconnell yesterday apparently
responsible for what happened
when he was thrown out of his own
chamber by a bunch of thugs and rioters
but joy reid says he's responsible too
the united states senate will not be
intimidated
we will not be kept out of this chamber
by thugs mobs
or threats they tried to disrupt our
democracy
they failed they failed
they failed to attempt to obstruct the
congress this failed insurrection only
underscores how crucial
the task before us is for our republic
okay but he's responsible right joy
you're responsible i'm responsible we
are all responsible
anyone who voted for trump anyone who
considered voting for trump you're all
responsible if you're in conservative
media
and you said as i did that trump has all
available legal challenges to him
but everything has a legal process and
you have to show proof of value you're
still responsible everyone's responsible
right this is the slander
okay because understand this is part and
parcel of a broader agenda point
for the political left the broader
agenda point is to treat you as a threat
if you disagree with them
you're just as bad as the people who
storm the us capital right you must be
silenced
you have to be shut up because you are
responsible for that
that matter if you condemned it you're
responsible that's the perspective of
joy raid if you think that i'm
exaggerating
this let me just point out that cory
bush
right a member of black lives matter
right that's how she started off was as
a
an activist at black lives matter she
introduced a resolution calling for the
expulsion of
any republican member of congress who
challenged any of the electoral college
results
now i disagreed with their challenges to
the actual college results i don't
believe they had a legal basis
for the their challenges to the
electoral college results but you cannot
expel
members of congress for voting a
particular way on a particular question
that is not how any of this works that
is a violation of the first amendment
it is a violation of basic principles of
free speech i disagree with cory bush on
everything
i can't vote to ex she shouldn't be
expelled from congress
i mean what what what the hell are we
talking about but again understand
that for a lot of people what happened
yesterday is a brick bat to be used
against anyone they disagree with right
chuck todd in the media doing the same
thing so chuck todd yesterday
he was pointing out that a lot of
republicans who are on board for the
electoral challenge were also condemning
the violence you could do both
you could do both again this is coming
from somebody who disagreed with the
electoral vote challenge
but to say that josh halley is somehow
responsible for people climbing into the
u.s capitol building
because he because he was promulgating
what i think are untruths
about voter fraud and the legitimacy of
the election
or or beyond that i mean it's not just
josh halley right i mean they're they're
trying to extend this to every single
republican
to everyone right here was chuck todd
yesterday
marco rubio now calling for the
president to say
something um they're they're pleading
with him on twitter
i mean and that is isn't that just the
that and it's
just of of the past four years
please mr president i have to talk to
you on twitter to try and restore
order i don't know there's a lot of
empty rhetoric there's a lot of empty
concern
you know this is one of those things i
think a lot of people are
having their i told you so moment
unfortunately right now
a lot of people have so basically
anybody anybody
who worked with trump over the past four
years is responsible for this
anyone you voted for him you liked his
judicial picks you liked what he did in
terms of foreign policy
you're responsible for this this is
going to be the end goal right so we've
had these three narratives those were
the three narratives the three
narratives were
one this is racial because america's
white supremacist incredibly ridiculous
narrative
two that riots are okay when the left
does it but they're very bad when when
people on the right do it
and three that all conservatives are
responsible for stuff they overtly
condemn
hate and despise because after all
conservative rhetoric invariably
this this has a long history okay going
all the way back to like the
assassination of jfk when the media
tried to blame
right-wingers for jfk's assassination
despite the fact he was killed by a
communist
i mean this goes all the way back to the
media trying to blame rush limbaugh for
the oklahoma city bombing
so this is just part and parcel of a
democratic talking point but now
it has picked up significant momentum
barack obama of course complicit in this
so obama put out a statement saying
pretty much this right he says
for two months he said he says
let me find the exact verbiage because
it's pretty incredible he says history
will rightly remember today's violence
at the capitol incited by a sitting
president who has continued to
baselessly lie about the outcome of a
lawful election
as a moment of great dishonor and shame
for our nation but we'd be kidding
ourselves if we treated it as a total
surprise
for two months now a political party and
its accompanying media ecosystem
has been largely unwilling to tell their
followers the truth that this was not a
particularly close election and that
president-elect biden will be
inaugurated on january 20th
their fantasy narrative has spiraled
further and further from reality and it
builds upon years
of sown resentments now we're seeing the
consequences whipped up into a violent
crescendo
first of all that's not what a crescendo
is but that's a side point right now
republican leaders have a choice made
clear in the in desecrating
in the desecrated chambers of democracy
they can continue down this road and
keep stoking the raging fires
or they can choose reality and take the
first steps start extinguishing
the flames they can choose america right
it's the entire political party
it's the entire accompanying media
ecosystem it's everyone you watch
it's fox news it's daily wire it's every
podcast you listen to they are all part
of the problem
weird because it seems like that was um
the preconceived notion of democrats all
the way through it's always republicans
who are the problem all of them
okay by the way this is how you get more
polarization
this is how you get more division by
labeling people responsible for
activities they are not responsible for
this is how it is done and it is
horrifying and it is disgusting
chuck schumer jumped on this yesterday
okay so chuck schumer in the senate
chamber the senate minority leader after
comparing this
to pearl harbor which again
that was a sneak attack by a military
power against the united states ending
with thousands of american deaths
but chuck schumer got up and uh and he
said
this is on not just trump but everybody
who follows trump
every single person is on you you 73
million americans who voted for trump
this is on you
way to bring the country together here
senate minority leader
now january 6 will go down as one of the
darkest days in recent american history
a final warning to our nation about the
consequences of a demagogic president
the people who enable him the captive
media that parrots his lies
and the people who follow him
as he attempts to push america to the
brink
of ruin okay so again the the idea here
this could be a unifying moment
right there was this kind of wonderful
moment for america after all this
horror happened yesterday after all this
this these terrible images went out to
the world
it's disgraceful disgraceful stuff after
all that happened
there was this moment of unification it
really felt unifying right all the
senators were ushered back into the
chamber there's video of them being
accompanied by the
by the uh by the fbi and and members of
the
police brigade and swat they were being
they were being sent back to the senate
chambers to complete
their work and they were just being
paraded back in thank you for being here
and then the vice president of the
united states mike pence
has served it with donald trump who
refused trump's request that he violated
the law
by decertifying electoral college votes
mike pence gave
a brief statement uh to the applause of
everyone in the chamber
saying that we need to get back to work
and do our constitutional duty because
this is a constitutional republic it is
not
a mobocracy this could have been a
moment when everybody left right and
center
said that's true we have a system the
system held
jackasses storming the capitol building
did not stop the system from working
here was mike pence's statement
yesterday as we reconvene in this
chamber
the world will again witness the
resilience
and strength of our democracy
for even in the wake of unprecedented
violence and vandalism
at this capitol the elected
representatives
of the people of the united states have
assembled again
on the very same day to support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
so may god bless the lost the injured
and the heroes forged on this day
may god bless all who serve here
and those who protect this place
and may god bless the united states of
america
let's get back to work okay so there was
this uniquely
kind of wonderful moment for just a
second and then
chuck schumer got up and said that
everybody on the right was responsible
for this and we are back
where we were and uh and i don't think
it's going to move forward i don't
because here is where things are going
to end here's where things are going to
move
uh this is this is the natural outcome
after all this is over and you can see
it happening
so twitter suspended trump yesterday he
put up that video that we played a
little bit earlier
he put up that video he claimed that you
gotta remember this day
right i don't like the video i don't
like the tweet i don't think they did
nearly enough in tamping down what was
happening or in telling his
followers the truth which is that the
election has been called it is now over
and that frankly the the allegations
that he made have been largely
unsubstantiated and
almost entirely debunked when they have
been actually pegged down to anything
specific
so twitter announced yesterday that they
had suspended trump for 12 hours
this is precisely the wrong move you
don't suspend the sitting president of
the united states frankly i don't think
the twitter should be suspending
people based on their promulgation of
data that twitter doesn't like
or that is untrue even i think that free
the the answer to bad speech is more
speech
i thought this used to be a basically
american principle that we we don't
throw people off of platforms for saying
things that we think are untrue
so twitter said it would lock trump's
twitter account that is not going to
convince any of his followers
any of them the ones who are who are
doing this sort of stuff
that he is um that he is wrong it's not
going to do any of that
then facebook took down trump's video
facebook suggested that trump's video
well the actual statement
is that they were taking down trump's
video specifically
because they thought it did more harm
than good which is a judgment call right
i mean i may even agree with that
judgment but that doesn't matter it's a
judgment call he did call for peace in
the video even though he was saying a
bunch of other stuff that i really
disagree with
guy rosen who's the vp of integrity at
facebook
he tweeted out this is an emergency
situation we are taking appropriate
emergency measures including removing
president trump's video we removed it
because on balance we believe it
contributes to
rather than diminishes the risk of
ongoing violence so let me just point
out how many videos went around
on facebook during the blm riots that
actively encouraged the violence
justified the violence and said that it
was okay
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
everybody can see the double standard
everybody can see how this is eventually
going to morph
into the banning of pretty much all
wrong think
facebook announced it will now remove
all photos and videos posted from the
protest all of them
he said first we've been searching for
and removing the following content
praise and support of the storming of
the us capital
calls to bring weapons to locations
across the us not just in washington but
anywhere in the united states including
protest
incitement or encouragement of the
events at the capitol including any
video or photo from the protesters
at this point they represent promotion
of criminal activity which violates our
policies do they do any of that with the
blm riots
i don't recall them doing any of that
with the blm riots at all like none
calls for protests even peaceful ones if
they violate the curfew in dc that
certainly did not happen with the blm
riots in protest
not not for a second not for a heartbeat
facebook didn't say okay you know what
curfew 6 p.m we're taking down all the
calls
and organizational efforts for a
peaceful protest in a park
they never did that ever as part of this
we removed from facebook and instagram
the recent video of president trump
speaking about the protests and his
subsequent post about the election
results we made that decision
that on balance the posts contribute
rather than diminish the risk of ongoing
violence
okay so this is going to be the talking
point going forward as your speech is
diminished
right what happened yesterday is
terrible what's going to happen in the
future if you start seeing an overt
attempt to shut down free speech
on the basis of what the germans call
stripe bear democracy right the
protection of democracy requires
that you not allow certain rhetoric you
bring that to the united states you
expand the definition of incitement you
expand the definition of damaging speech
and pretty soon you have a complete
shutdown
of free speech and dissenting points of
view because the left has a real
tendency
to expand the definition of harm
right the speech that that is free and
does not call for violence it could be
inside it could be incitement it could
be harmful
it could be damaging the microaggression
culture cultivated by the left
suggests that anything that
right-wingers say anyone anything
conservative say anything that
americans who simply are not woke say is
damaging in the extreme
right it's an attack on identity if this
becomes part and parcel of a broader
attack on free speech which it
absolutely could
and there is every indicator that it
will that's a tremendous danger
to the future of the republic the
solution to all of this
was is will continue to be the
rebuilding of the social fabric
that has always meant the same thing it
has always meant the same thing
you condemn in the strongest possible
terms
actual violations of law you condemn
riots no matter if you
agree with the cause people are rioting
for or you don't you condemn writing you
condemn violence
you say that it's disgusting because it
is disgusting
you provide solidarity for people who
are exercising their rights but no
solidarity
for people who are violating the rights
of others and violating the law
this is so not hard and yet all the
political incentives
are aligned in precisely the opposite
direction there are a lot of people who
make
bank off of telling you that things that
are bad are good
there are a lot of people out there who
make bank telling you that all of the
people who you dislike politically
they're actually on the side of the
devil right that they are morally evil
and that all the people who you like
politically are actually on the side of
the angels no matter how bad
they actually are that has to stop
look at your friends look your neighbors
look your social groups realize
that all of them if they are good people
look at what happened yesterday with
horror
and shock and that if we're all
americans at least that much we should
agree upon and it doesn't matter if
we're talking about violence done at the
capitol building or violence done in
kenosha
this kind of activity cannot go on in
the united states of america
yesterday was an egregious symbol of the
state to which our republic
has sunk we need to pick ourselves up
remember that we are still members of
the same country
look to the constitution as our guide
follow the law
and recognize that we are still citizens
of the greatest republic in the history
of the world
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show coming up soon the matt
wall show check out his show airing
1 30 pm eastern over at dailywire.com
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen